you
hello and welcome to my talk on
improving low connectivity experiences
on the web I'm Valerie Willard
Srinivasan I work at panoply the podcast
network so yes podcasts if you want
podcast recommendations definitely catch
me in the hallway later but for now I
want to talk a little bit about the
internet also I have my twitter handle
up here
valerie codes feel free to tweet me your
thoughts favorite quotes favorite
podcasts whatever i'd love to hear about
hear from you but first let's talk a
little bit about the internet I love the
internet we all probably do I'm willing
to guess that most of us here have spent
plenty of time they're given the topics
of this conference and are used to
putting it to use for many aspects of
our personal and professional lives this
is one of my favorite things from the
internet it's an owl with a tiny Santa
hat on but the Internet is not just a
great place for finding cute owls with
Santa hats it's an incredibly important
tool we're all fans of the internet and
work with it every day we've seen the
power and impact that our work can have
and wouldn't it be great if that were
available to more people but while I'm
willing to bet that pretty much everyone
in this room has a reliable high-speed
Internet connection at home or at work
or let's be honest probably both that's
far from the case for the rest of the
world 54% of households worldwide have
internet access 84% of households in
developed countries and only 15% of
households in least developed countries
have access to the Internet some of
these users might only be able to get
online from a mobile phone network or
from their local library so perhaps it
goes without saying the more forgiving
your applications or websites are two
people who have slow or limited in
internet access the more people will be
able to use them opening up additional
possibilities for viewers or customers
from around the globe
it's also worth noting the regional and
economic variations in internet
accessibility and keeping in mind that
internet speed could be a hurdle to
people in lower income brackets or from
rural areas using your site this makes
me think of this quote by William Gibson
the future is already here it's just not
very evenly distributed as well as being
the home for almost all of the work that
we as developers do the Internet has a
lot of promise to level disparities
caused by difference in class education
and access in many ways it is the future
but just like the future the Internet is
not evenly distributed either we saw on
the last slide that there are huge
differences in countries internet access
due to wealth wealth and infrastructure
in addition to that rural households are
less likely to have internet access
poorer families are less likely to have
internet access and more likely to only
access the internet on a smartphone
rather than a computer people with more
education are more likely to access the
Internet men are more likely than women
young people are more likely than older
people so while there may be not much we
can do for users who never access the
internet ever at all there are lots of
ways that we can help users who may have
limited internet access and there are
lots of ways that access can be limited
let's talk about the different types of
ways people can be internet limited
people may fall into multiple of these
categories and they might may not be
permanent or apply to all of the ways in
which a person accesses the Internet
first there's the intermittent
connection we've all probably
experienced this as we try to use our
mobile data network as we're on the
train or going between service areas
this could also be a fixed Internet
access point that is unreliable due to
service providers or whether in these
cases the phone or computer may even
report that is it's connected to a
network
but packets are not actually being
delivered
next there's the slow connection where a
reliable connection exists but it may be
much slower than what we're used to
making it difficult to load websites
with lots of rich content or background
scripts there's also the
bandwidth-limited connection which again
we're probably much more familiar with
on our phone but also exists on home
internet plans some users may be limited
to to a certain number of gigabytes of
data data use a month making them have a
much higher awareness of how much data
they're actually using some people may
also have sporadic or time limited
connections which I've differentiated
from internet Mitton connections because
they may be able to predict that they'll
only be able to access the internet from
their their local library at a certain
time or a person who only connects to
the Internet in a given time frame and
may want to cache or save content for
later this is the part where I embarrass
my mom I also made her take this picture
for me it is of her internet satellite
dish as you might guess she and my dad
lack access to high-speed Internet there
are no fibre or DSL lines up here what
there is is a clear view of the southern
sky so they get satellite internet with
a top speed of 5 megabits per second for
probably more than some of you pay for
your much cozier plans to top it off
they also have bandwidth caps that limit
their totally data usage to 10 gigabytes
a month and at the time this picture was
taken as may be evident they didn't have
any internet access at all because their
internet satellite dish was covered in
snow during the winter one of my parents
has to go out and periodically clean it
off if they want to keep using the
Internet here's a full list of the
internet plans available for from the my
parents internet provider you'll notice
that the top download speed is 5
megabits per second which is much lower
than the 25 megabits per second required
for that
CiCi's classification of high-speed
you'll also notice that all of the plans
have fairly low bandwidth limits if you
consider that streaming a movie can
easily consume a gigabyte of data but
there's unlimited data usage from
midnight to 5:00 a.m. so you can get all
your downloading done then the
limitations of this plan fall into three
of the categories that I discussed
earlier it's slower than we're all used
to its bandwidth limited and it's time
limited in that it's advantageous to get
all your data transfers done in the
unlimited window with these complaint
constraints in mind let's continue
problems are of limited connectivity are
not just limited to people in rural
areas here's a tweet from just a few
days ago from someone visiting Germany
who had limited data speeds
I think Nicole is actually at this
conference and this is from a story that
the New York Times did in August of 2015
entitled the costs of mobile ads on 50
news sites it was focusing on the cost
of loading these sites to mobile users
both in terms of little literal cost on
their phone plans and time spent waiting
for things to load but as we've seen a
lot of the challenges that apply to
mobile internet usage are also relevant
to other limited connectivity users it
found that most new sites took longer to
load ad content than editorial content
in some egregious examples up to three
times longer that means that you're
waiting three times longer time for your
ads to load then for the actual article
that you wanted to read given that these
sites rely heavily on advertising for
their revenue it doesn't seem like a
great idea for their ad scripts or
content to reduce speed to such a level
that people are incentivized to install
ad blockers this is an important point
to consider also as we consider
advertising within our projects and the
larger question
whether the costs to the user of viewing
or using our content is being spent in
loading content that is integral to what
the app does or whether it is added
features fun or polish if the things
that we're making users load aren't
essential are we giving them a way to
opt out just to illustrate this point a
little further with another recent
example USA today's European version of
their site got rid of tracking scripts
to comply with GDP are as a result the
size of an individual page went from
five megabytes to just 500 kilobytes
some users don't mind advertising but
they shouldn't have to sacrifice
performance in order to use to load ads
so where does that leave us
one of the most important things that
you can do to support these types of
users is to build responsive websites
more and more users are accessing the
internet from mobile phones and for many
especially lower-income people that is
the only way they access the Internet in
addition to being tolerant to flaky
networks as people move in and out of
coverage areas any website or app
serving these users needs to be
responsive and performed properly on a
small screen and possibly underpowered
device another important thing we can do
is just communicate signal and allow
people to opt out of high bandwidth
portions of your site for example from
both a bandwidth and a user experience
perspective there's really no reason for
you to have an auto playing video on
your site users should know any time
they're about to download a file you can
use little download symbols and indicate
the file size if possible it should be
clear to users when they're about to
start playing a video or stream which
again should never autoplay think about
how you structure your content remember
that sites are loaded top to bottom so
by putting important things at the
beginning of your HTML document
those things will load first allowing
users with slow internet to have
something to read before all of the
content finishes loading place large
assets or Java scripts toward the end if
it's not essential that baby loaded as
soon as the page renders I had to
include this because I was adapting this
talk for a European audience and I know
you like soccer I like animals this
combines the two talking about headers
optimize your caching by getting
familiar with what cache headers you're
setting and trying to avoid users having
to refetch content if it hasn't changed
things like fonts style sheets other
static assets are all examples of things
that probably don't change much over
time and you can improve your users
experience by not forcing a reload every
time here are some guidelines based on
UX research and attention it takes about
one second for users to notice that
they're waiting for something to load
and start getting impatient it's ideal
to have at least some content loaded
after two seconds even if you can't load
the entire page in that time frame on a
slow connection it'll at least give the
user something to do while they wait
after 10 seconds a user will start to
lose interest and is likely to be
diverted by another task it should take
one minute or less for a user to
complete a simple task on your app like
signing up or making a purchase longer
than that and users will start to
perceive sluggishness so you can try
testing some of these guidelines and
simulating a degraded Network
environment and see how long they take
on your sites
I found this recommendation from a UK
NGO from about 10 years ago that
recommended an upper limit on page size
of 25 kilobytes this was based on the
connection speeds of universities in
Africa and the rationale that such a
page would take 10 seconds to load over
a 20
kilobit per second connection but as a
lot of you probably know this is really
small this may not be a realistic
guideline for a lot of people it's older
and the infrastructure may have improved
but at the same time limiting page size
is very important in light of that
recommendation let's look at some of the
common libraries that we're probably all
using jQuery clocks in at 85 kilobytes
bootstraps j/s is 50 kilobytes whereas
it's CSS is another 125 d3 is 216
kilobytes of course these are necessary
parts of lots of sites for various
reasons but it's worth being aware of
the cost of these inclusions especially
as we consider that these are all before
we get to the size of any of the actual
content on your web site and the cost of
including these libraries for
bandwidth-limited users if you're using
jQuery for a couple functions that are
possible but a little ugly or without it
maybe consider making that sacrifice if
you'd like to check the sizes of pages
yourself the network tab on chrome dev
tools can help with profiling us if you
disable the cache and load a page it'll
give you the total size of data
transferred and of course with caching
this is probably not the amount of data
users actually have to load on every
page load but it can still give you some
idea I tried measuring the size of a
couple pages in chrome dev tools they
were all at least a couple hundred
kilobytes and plenty went well into the
megabytes Google's PageSpeed insights is
another great resource you can take a
URL and it'll give suggestions for how
to make that page faster so the ideas
we've talked about so far are helpful
for people with slow internet
connections or limited bandwidth but
what about the separate issue of an
unreliable internet connection or one
that says it's connected but isn't
there's a growing movement toward
offline first development which assumes
that a user does not have connection and
serves from a cache and if there is
connection updated information can be
fetched and rendered of course it's not
magic and only works if the user has
successfully connected before in order
to populate the cache but at least it
does not assume that they need a
reliable connection every single time
email clients are probably the sorts of
applications that were most familiar
with it used this paradigm even if you
aren't connected you can see the
messages downloaded from the last time
you were you can even write messages
that are queued up to be sent next time
you have a connection paradigm is part
of progressive web app development and
can also be applied to your slick sites
and web apps
the idea of offline first is especially
helpful to mobile users and others who
might not be able to predict when
they'll be offline adding additional UI
signals like google drives make
available offline can aid in those
scenarios with some research you'll find
lots of resources around offline first
and how to start using it
I recommend the article designing
offline first web apps on a list apart
as a primer on the topic and some of the
best practices and ideas around it as
well as resources on how to contribute
your ideas and learn more the big idea
is that being offline is normal and
something that should be treated as such
rather than just throwing an error or
exception a serviceworker is now
supported on all major browsers it runs
as soon as the page is requested and
before that request is sent out to the
network and conserve from a cache if the
network is unavailable serviceworker
introduces a new storage API a place to
store responses keyed by requests
similar to the browser cache but it
gives you a lot more control over what
and how content is cached then a simple
browser header this can allow you to
tell browsers to cache your pages and
content locally so that if a user loses
internet connection they can still
access your site
as you set up a serviceworker you
actually have a lot of control over how
it works
so you could have it display a custom
your offline page similar to a 404 page
or you can get more creative by having
it cash the last couple articles that a
user has read on your site or maybe the
most common content that people come to
your site for you can also put use this
to put control back into the users hands
by giving them some sort of UI option to
save something for online use or for
offline use here's Google Chrome's
default online page you can play a
little game with the tier X which makes
it somewhat less frustrating another
useful tool in Google Chrome is that you
can simulate different network
conditions in developer tools so you can
test how your website or what web app
looks and performs to users on different
types of connections so before we part
ways I want to talk a bit more about why
I think this topic is important this
quote is from a story on limit limited
connectivity users primarily those using
only a phone and their access to news
sites as you can imagine as capabilities
improve to make the most complex
infographics and most flashy and
interactive features keep in mind the
users that you may be leaving behind as
you make those choices it's really easy
to always want to be on the cutting edge
always working in the coolest technology
but we have to remember that that's all
privileged in many places that's a quote
from era Aaron Williams a graphics
reporter at the Washington Post from a
pure business perspective the best way
to reach more customers is to make your
product available and useful to more
people if your product website or app
has a billion possible users chances are
good that some of them will be in the
groups we talked about earlier who have
limited internet access be that due to
Geographic limitations economic
limitations or some combination of the
two
it's also worth remembering that
constant and reliable internet
connectivity is a privilege and by
leaving out those who don't have it
we're leaving out a specific segment of
the population largely rural and or low
income in the last year in the United
States we've been involved in a very
heated exchange around the Internet's
role in shaping our country our politics
and our policies as we come to rely on
the internet more and more in our daily
lives both in our logistics and our
decision-making we need to be aware of
the consequences that making our tools
and information inaccessible to low
connectivity users has access to
legitimate news sources was a huge issue
in the last u.s. election and one that
is likely to continue to loom large as
time goes on we look specifically here
at news sites and the toll that
advertising scripts can take on low
connectivity users if those users aren't
able to load legitimate news sites then
we're in trouble
if services applications or tools are
similarly unavailable to that group we
have a huge problem think about this and
your responsibilities in this system as
you develop websites and design tools
for the future I hope that this has
given you some more context and tools
for supporting and empathizing with low
connectivity users in your development
process if nothing else I hope that I've
convinced you to never add an auto
playing video to your website I'd love
to hear more from you my twitter handle
is valerie codes and my email is Valerie
Willard at gmail.com again my name is
Valerie Willard Srinivasan if you're
interested in podcast programming and
living in the Washington DC area I'd
love to talk more about roles at panoply
or we can just talk about our favorite
podcasts thank you again for having me
I'll be posting these slides shortly on
my Twitter feed and including links to
citations and more resources